sie ist ein shooting star der
amerikanischen kunstszene shader soliman
ihre kunst eindringliche skulpturen
kreiert das fotos hingerichtete
misshandelter frau und mir an meiner
bilder zeigen motive von frauen denen
man säure ins gesicht gespritzt hat oder
auch rita bari wo hingerichtet wurde
weil sie ihren vergewaltiger angegriffen
hatte kabarett wurde trotz
internationaler proteste ende 2014
gehängt im prozess hatte sie bis zuletzt
beteuert ihren vergewaltiger in notwehr
getötet zu haben
da wir diese bilder dieser frauen immer
noch online möchte ich ihnen eine neue
existenz das macht sie natürlich nicht
wieder lebendig aber ich möchte dass die
menschen wissen dass es diese frauen
gegeben hat und dass sie sterben wenn
man diesen hinrichtungen mehr beachtung
schenkt dann könnte der westen beginnen
dies deutlicher zu hinterfragen
klar das interesse des westens gilt er
der industrie der wirtschaft und dem öl
warum nicht auf den menschenrechten
irans präsident hu anni gilt im westen
als gemässigter politiker und die
meisten wirtschaftssanktionen gegen sein
land wurden aufgehoben
die menschenrechtssituation hat sich
jedoch nicht wesentlich verbessert
letztes jahr wurden fast tausend
menschen exekutiert
darunter auch minderjährige ein
eklatanter bruch internationalen rechts
vor allem den weiblichen opfern des
mullah-regimes möchte die künstlerin ein
gesicht geben
meine eltern sind beide politische
flüchtlinge der iranischen revolution
von 1979 mein vater war aktivist gegen
das totalitäre regime tollers meine
mutter war nie wirklich politisch aktiv
aber sie wurde für die proteste und
aktionen meines vaters mitverantwortlich
gemacht
ein jahr lang war sie im gefängnis
musste das irgendwann für craft wissen
sie viele leute der iranischen regierung
haben sie misshandelt und sie hat immer
noch viele schlimme erinnerungen
ich bin aufgewachsen die um geschichten
wenn sie mich ins bett brachten haben
sie mir statt gute nacht geschichten oft
von der revolution erzählt von der zeit
die man heute im gefängnis verbracht hat
für ihre neue serie oblivion durchforste
zur manie das netz nach schicksal
manchmal findet sie fotos gesichter von
frauen die gewaltsam zum verschwinden
gebracht worden sie vergrößert solche
fotos und drückt sie auf textilgewebe
mit dem open entstehen zum teil
lebensgroße zeugnisse der tragischen
frauenschicksal die schilder solle man
ihn nicht in vergessenheit geraten
lassen will
willich die puppen anfertige gestalte
ich anschließend ein szenario eine
kulisse in der sie existieren kann wie
einem standbild oder auf einer bühne
durch diese montage erhalten die
abbilder der getöteten frauen eine neue
art von realität das ist quatsch sie
wurde hingerichtet weil sie angeblich
eine frau getötet hatte die etwas mit
ihrem mann gehabt habe ich wollte ihr
nicht wehtun
in der art wie ich sollte sie nicht zu
grob aus stoff vor anfassen
diese als sinnbild für einen salsa wir
werden nicht gleich behandelt innerhalb
der gesellschaft sogar hier in den
vereinigten staaten aber im iran ist es
umfasst dort sind die frauen der box
sagte gesellschaft manchmal hört man
nachrichten über rebellion im iran
doch dann stirbt er hat eine berühmtheit
und schon ist diese rebellion verdrängt
mein job ist es das erbe fortzuführen
und weiter über dieses thema zu sprechen